the nintendo's been known to drop a bunt
down
at times but why when you're swinging
that good
and he is and that ball is driven in the
gap right center field and that will
drop
and ben attended not stopping at second
base
he will make it to third with a triple
continues to hit burrill had some air
time on it
center fielder celestina was over
and playing him to the opposite field a
little bit nice effort but just couldn't
quite get to it
and he gave all he had six for 31
against burrill so sub
200 batting average
[Music]
nice pickup at third by donaldson to end
the inning
a triple is wasted on the basis and
we've got a scoreless first in kansas
city
seems like he isn't overwhelmed by any
situation
[Applause]
reacted like he thought he might defeat
marina we'll see if the twins take a
look at it
but he's definitely safe he's safe at
first but in coming out of the dugout
see i was thinking we maybe had a little
gamesmanship after the play that wasn't
reviewed but it was a return in
yesterday's ball game maybe rocco was
trying to
you know go through the same thing he
saw hey you think you could change that
call without me burning a review
and we believe the twins just
successfully challenged
there's carol off at first challenging
the outcome
at second well he kicked the bag it
looked like with his right foot
so we'll go with the fact that the
challenge is at first base
two down now and ryan jeffers will bat
that was a very hittable pitch right
there he'd like to have that one back
see if
jefferson gets the same thing if he's
able to do some damage
he did that is damage
jeffers with a two-run home run and the
twins take the first lead
yeah not the same pitch but the same
location as the one that snow just
missed and popped a mile in the air this
one
jeffers has looked so comfortable since
he's been back up he went down to
st paul got a little reset got some
consistent playing time and
now he's looking like that guy that we
saw last year real good sign and good
bounce back for the twins to take the
lead early in this game
mention that mitch garver was swinging
the bat well
and we've talked often about mitch's
short swing
short follow-through looks like jeffers
has got a little bit of that too
so michael a taylor will step to the
plate
255 batting average five hits
on this home stand including a double
and a triple
jammed him again donaldson doesn't have
a play that's a hit all the way base hit
nice job so after you know
a hitter can tell how they're pitching
you and where they're going to keep
coming
so taylor knew inside was where they
were going to go and donaldson on the
transfer couldn't make the play and look
there's not i'm not sure he would have
thrown him out that's why you can't
give him an error on that
royals have them loaded
with merrifield coming up this is where
you might want to look for that fastball
with a no one count
and he gets one up the middle that's a
base hit and it's going to tie the game
field comes through again with the bases
loaded
he is a master at finding holes
like you were saying the pitching coach
came out there
jewess johnson what was he talking about
well
he's going to hit the ball you just hope
he hits it at somebody sure enough he
didn't
whip continues to stay hot with him
loaded and with reverse in scoring
position
and it'll be kyle garlick to start the
third inning for the twins against mike
miner
[Applause]
and garlic looks like he got a change up
again this time he plasters up the left
they call that making an adjustment
right there this one over the plate but
miners shook to it twice sally put down
fastball he said no
he put down slider he said no he wanted
that change up he threw it over the
plate and garlic
gave the twins the lead back
back in front yeah the change up
left belt high and garlic punished it i
think the difference between this one in
the first at-bat he was in a one-two
count he didn't have to throw that one
over the plate this time
no place to put him this time i think he
was just going as soon as he
lifts his leg i'm going first movement
and there's a base hit away from the
shift
crews is coming around third here's the
throw to the plate
and then got him
salvador perez places the tag on nelson
cruz
and he is out that's right michael
a taylor was couldn't wait for a ball to
come to him
gets it throws right on the third base
side of the plate
[Applause]
he was one of those student athletes
majored in physics in college wanted to
be an aerospace engineer and he drives
this one to center
and taylor is way back and michael runs
into the
blue cross blue shield side and remakes
a
remarkable catch that was extra bases
written all over it michael a taylor
loves the space here he has to run in
when you're an athlete
you can make plays like that wasn't sure
exactly where he was he didn't get that
last
peek but he couldn't take his eye off
the ball the sun
the wind all play on that baseball while
it's traveling out there miner says
thank you
there it is go sit ball it's gonna
drop fair and lopez has himself a two
base hit to open this fifth inning oh
boy he has had a good series man i'll
tell you what
that's a great at-bat there outstanding
start now it's time to
get him on get him over get him in tie
this game up look at that that's nikki
lopez right there didn't try to pull it
so now it's been to see if ben and teddy
can pick them all up
and intend he will get help from that
win yes
yes he does
andrew bennett tendy stays red-hot
ben and tindy sixth home run of the
season
all four of the royals runs today scored
with two outs
pressuring barrios what a swing
because the spin you know is going to
come back towards the field from
right-handed battery there
then cruz says okay just fine i'll uh
hit one to center field sharply
and crew's digging for second base and
he is
safe a second nellie cruz with a stolen
base earlier and a hustle double
here in the sixth he's safe that's a
great slide right there good aggressive
base running play
why not take a chance get yourself in
scoring position he's had some huge hits
that have won him some games you know
pitch hit homer a big three run homer a
three home run game i mean he's had
he's had some good days but they've been
too many offers in between those
and a high days to left field that's not
a single
that's a mammoth home run and the twins
are back in front
that's a strong man right there got
himself just a little spinner that
goes a long way if you don't throw that
where you want to you see shelby
perez's target on the ground and see
donaldson's reaction you see ceno's
reaction and there's no doubt about that
one and this ball is as far as you can
hit a baseball
and he passes the baton on to dyson here
he comes
and listens to this crowd
dave short simmons drops it
[Applause]
you might as well have them take a look
well that's a tough gamble right there
you know you got to go glover simmons
now
watch him he's going to pick this ball
up off balance and flip it throws his
strike dyson was hoping it was a bad
throw
out oh my oh and the royals dugout is
furious nobody's he's safe he's out at
first but he's safe
oh okay because why did nelson come away
and go
out we knew that jorge soler was
[Applause]
the eighth out hitter two outs to go
two strikes to the batter
[Applause]
and a double play a bullet to simmons
and the twins win the ball games
five to four